Mark: HELLO
Ethan: what?
Mark: Hi how's it goin?
My name is Markiplier and welcome to the whisper challenge
if you don't know what the whisper challenge is he's gonna
Deep voice Mark: The whisper challenge
is where the other three participants
are listening to very loud music
and can't hear what I'm saying.
*Breath*
So I read the tweet, and
then whisper it very quietly to them,
They try to read my lips and interpret what I'm saying,
And then pass that along to the next person, like a game of telephone.
*Heavy Breathing*
Obviously, hilarity ensues afterwards.
Mark: And then, we're gonna see what it really was when it's over.
HAAAAHH
Anyway, you guys ready?
Tyler: Don't for-Don't forget to screenshot.
Mark: We- Yes. We've got suggestions here from YOU guys,
on #bigcranberries. 'Cause that's what we need for this Thanksgiving holiday
that is probably after Thanksgiving by the time you see this.
Never mind me, Big Ole Dumb Muster Mar-Markiplier.
Ethan: *giggles* Mustroom- Mushroom Mars-Markiplier. *more giggling*
Mark: *slightly yelling* Y-Your song's at a faster tempo than mine.
Ethan: I do have great pecs!
Tyler: Penguins are the only thing I don't have. (2x)
Mark: Penguins don't choose the pancake life.
*Tyler laughs wheezingly*
Penguins don't choose the pancake life.
Ethan: Okay
Mark: Alright?
Tyler: What is it?
Ethan: Put back those shoes, the pancake life.
Mark: You got the last part.
Tyler: You got the last two of his.
Mark: I said penguins don't choose the pancake life.
Tyler: Penguins are the only thing I don't have.
Mark and Ethan: OOOOOOHH *giggling*
*Everyone: laughs*
Mark: Somebody once told me the world is gonna roll me.
*more laughter*
Ethan: Somebody once told me the world is my homie.
Oh wait, I know what it is now.
Mark: Yeah, but you can't say that.
Ethan: Somebody once told me the world is my homie.
Tyler: Someone once told me the world is my oyster?
Mark and Ethan: No.
Ethan: What I said was, "Somebody once told me the world is my homie."
All:🎵Some-BODY once told me the world is gonna roll me, I ain't the sharpest tool in the sheeed.
Ethan: Don't sing, it angers the capybaras.
Tyler: Tony Hawk once sold me some applesauce.
Ethan: So Mark, what'd you get?
Mark: Jerking off in a barrel of applesauce? *Ethan and Tyler laughing*
That was like word-for-word!
Tyler: No, "Tony Hawk once sold me some applesauce," is what I said.
Mark: oooohhhohoho *giggles*
Ethan: And the original tweet was, "Don't sing, it angers the capybaras."
OOOOOOOOOOooooohh...?
Tyler: Floof the hair for power! (x2)
Mark: Food is fuel for the Power Rangers. (x2)
Ethan: *laughs*
Ethan: *gasp* S-so what I heard- *chuckles*
*more chuckling*
Tyler: I don't know what he heard!
Ethan: Force-fisting the Power Rangers.
(Everyone laughing)
Ethan: Force-fisting the Power Rangers. (laughs)
Mark: You're always so close.
Ethan: Oh no *giggling*
Mark: I *giggle* said "Food is fuel for the Power Rangers." Ethan: Ohhh, okay
Soo close.
Tyler: Floof the hair for power.
Oooooaaaaahhhhhh
*mouth noises*
Mark: Mark is the ultimate dabbing king. (x2)
Ethan: Burn the clothespin anemone.
Ethan: *giggling*
Mark: *quietly* w...what
Ethan: Burn the clothespin anemone.
Mark: How'd you get that?
Ethan: I don't know!
Mark: What?
Tyler: Put the zucchini on me?
Mark: No.
Ethan: I said, "Burn the clothespin anemone."
Mark: I gotta check the original, because I don't- I said, "Mark is the ultimate dabbing king."
Ethan: *chuckles* oh
Mark: How did you get that?
Ethan: Well, anemone-
Mark: Dabbing king...
Ethan: Dabbing king, kind of...
Mark: ...NO.
Tyler: Zucchini is closer to dabbing king.
Mark:  Anenom-anenom-anemon
*laughter*
Anemone and zucchini, I can definitely see, but mmm, my goodness... Tyler: *mocks Mark*
Ethan: Dobby has no master, Dobby is a free elf!
Tyler: CAN YOU TALK NORMAL FOR ONCE?
Tyler: THAT IS SO LONG, GO AGAIN!
Stop asking your master when you can go out with me. *giggle*
Mark: So FAST
Tyler: Stop asking your master when you can go out with me.
Mark: I GOT THIS ONE ON LOCK.
Put my ass in your pants and turn around and beat me! *Tyler and Ethan laugh uncontrollably.*
Is that what you said?
Is that what you said? No?
Tyler: Stop asking your master when you can go out with me.
ooohh ho- *laughter*
*even more laughter*
Tyler: You couldn't be farther off!
Mark: I think I was pretty close.
Ethan: Okay, and the real tweet was, "Dobby has no master, Dobby is a free elf!"
Mark and Tyler: ohh
Tyler: I got master!
Ethan: You did get master!
Mark: I didn't get anything! Put-Put your ass in my pants!
Tyler: Let's make some gingerbread men. (x2)
Tyler: *chuckle*
Mark: Tha-g-fu... I'm gonna hear one more cause I cannot be right on this!
One more, please. Don't make me say what I think you said.
Tyler: *wheeze* Okay.
Tyler: Let's make some gingerbread men.
Tyler: *wheeze*
Mark: I-I swear... I'm trying to get anything else, but what I think you said...
*mumbling* Lesbians have a machine-powered penis machine.
*Tyler and Ethan laugh*
Mark: Lesbians have a machine-powered penis machine.
*Ethan dies*
Mark: Was I close?
Tyler: No
*nervous laughter*
*Ethan cackles*
Ethan: Lesbians have pussy-powered penis poppers.
(All three laughing)
Ethan: Was that close?
Tyler: Close to what he said, not to what I said!
Mark: Wow
Mark: I said, "Lesbians have a machine-powered penis machine."
*Ethan laughing*
Tyler: The real thing is-
Mark: Please be close!
Tyler: Let's make some gingerbread men. *uncontrollable laughter*
Ethan: How?! How did you get lesbian machines?!
Mark: I don't know! I had him do it FOUR times!
Mark: Peter pooper picked his poopy puffy pants. (x2)
Ethan: Peter pooper picked his puffy poopy pants.
Tyler: Peter Piper's puffer penguins pooped my pants.
Mark: CLOSE!
He nailed it!
Ethan: Yehehes!
Mark: He nailed it! That's the first time it's ever happened!
Ethan: Yes!
We-Well we both said the same thing, "Peter Pooper picked his puffy poopy pants!"
Ethan: YES!
Ethan: AAAAAGGGGGGHHHH
Mark: WHOOAHH
Ethan and Mark: That was good!
Mark: Not funny, but good!
Ethan: That was real good.
Ethan: Why are there so many Bilbos? (x2)
Tyler: Why are there so many people? (x3)
Mark: Why are there so many short people?
Tyler: Why are there so many people?
Mark: oohh...
Ethan: Why are there so many Bilbos?
Mark and Tyler: Oohh
Ethan: Really close!
Mark: Three-way high five!
*slap*
*slapslapslapslapslap*
Ethan: Fuck.
*fake orgasm sounds from all three + lord of the rings references*  Various 'put it in my bilbo's' and sensual Sam' and 'Frobo's
*Laughter*
Mark: Anyway...
Tyler: My mac and cheese screams when I eat it.
Mark: We're off to a BAD start!
*exhale*
Mark: I'm not tryin' to do this, guys...
Tyler: You told me to pick ones that are tough.
Mark: My penis is struggling to contain its girth.
Ethan: *nervously* Do that again..?
Ethan: Maybe it's time for you to increase your girth.
*all laugh*
Mark: I said, "My penis is struggling to contain its girth."
Ethan: Oooooohhh.
Mark: I'm guessing that wasn't close at all.
Tyler: My mac and cheese screams when I eat it.
Ethan: Not even close.
Mark: How the fffuck?
Ethan: Not even close at all
Mark: Go up to the-Go up to the camera and silently say that line.
Mark: SEEEE??? The advantage is you know what it was before...
*laughter*
But, cut it so that- I- I don't know!
DAAAAAAAAAHHHH!!!
Mark: I really like the actor Bendydick Cumandsnap, don't you?
Ethan: Was that one thing?
Mark: Yes.
Ethan: Okay, go again.
Mark: I really like the actor Bendydick Cumandsnap, don't you?
Ethan: I really like the ass-demolisher, don't you?
*Mark cackles*
Ethan: That close?
Mark: It got close, yeah!
Ethan: I really like the ass-demolisher, don't you?
Tyler: I like eating basketball shorts, don't you?
Mark: Nooooo...
Ethan: I like the ass-demolisher, don't you?
Mark: I really like the actor Bendydick Cumandsnap, don't you?
*Mark giggles*
Ethan: Don't you?
Mark: Don't you like Bendydick Cumandsnap?
Mark: Who are you looking at?
Someone there?
Is someone recording this?
OH GOD NO!
Ethan: THEY'RE RECORDING US!
Mark: AAAH, FUUCK!
Ethan: OHHH NOOO
OHHH NO!
*laughter*
Ethan: Big moist is the opposite of small dry.
Tyler: WHY ARE YOU PICKING LONG ONES?!
Tyler: Big boys are the opposite of small kids.
Mark: YOUR LIPS ARE IMPOSSIBLE TO READ!
CAUSE EVERY
TIME
I SEE
PENIS!!
EVERY
TIME!
*giggling*When I look at your lips, I just see
PENIS!
Tyler: Big boys are the opposite of small kids.
Mark: I still saw penis... Alright-
Penis pumps are the opposite of Chipotle.
Tyler: Big bois-Big boys are the opposite of small kids.
Ethan: Pretty close!
Ethan: The real tweet was-*pained Mark cry*, "Big moist is the opposite of small dry."
Tyler: I got really close!
Mark: Yeah you got close
Mark: I had the middle part.
Ethan: Yeah you got the middle part
Mark: I just see- Whenever he's talking, it's just PENIS!
Ethan: Put your PENIS in my mouth.
Mark *giggles while speaking*: I got dick on the miiind.
That was the-That was the whisper challenge. AAAH.
Tyler: I thought we were doing one more?
Noo, Imma end it now, cause my god...
I remember why we stopped doing that.
Tyler: I like Chica wigwag.
Mark: It just makes me look bad...
So thank you everybody so much for watching,
if you wanna see more of this...let us know.
it just, ends up with dick a lot...
It's just like the predominate subject in our conversations.
It is! Admit-Admit it! There's a lot of dick...
Tyler: SAVE YOURSEL-
Everyone: *Laughs*
Mark: SAVE YOURSELF!
Mark while dabbing uncontrollably: AAAAAAAAAA *falls*
Tyler and Ethan: *continue to laugh*
Mark: Okay so thanks again everybody so much for watching let me know what you thought
or us know, down in the description below.
or comments. Whatever.
Ethan: *Laughs* In the description..
Mark: Down there somewhere. Just start writing on your monitor, down below
and uh, we'll see.
Oh yeah, Ethan's channel and then Tyler's twitter is in the description.
So thanks again everybody for watching. And as always, we'll see you-
in the next one!
video...woah
Tyler and Ethan: *begin laughing*
How many times have I been doing that outro?
How many?
And as always, we will see yoou-
in the next video! Buh-Bye!
Ethan: Bye!
Tyler: Bye!